[Música]
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos
a mais uma live. É um prazer táar aqui
com vocês
e nós temos aí por volta de 20 perguntas
ao do documento e então pode ser que tem
tenha tempo de responder as dúvidas
também que estão aparecendo aqui no
chat, OK?
Boa noite, Eliseu. Boa noite,
Ana Paula. Quem mais tá ao vivo, Irma?
São esses três nomes que eu tô vendo
aqui nas perguntas e comentários. Bem,
vamos começar a apresentação.
Deixa eu fazer assim, acho que melhor.
Esse Qcode tá aparecendo aí na tela,
pessoal. Qual é o Qcode de um
questionário sobre a questão do monitor
de cetose? Tá? Se vocês viram a live que
nós fizemos domingo de manhã com a
nutricionista
Andreia Torres, é para saber quantos
vocês teriam interesse de tá utilizando
esse recurso, OK?
Bem, vamos lá. Poderia falar um pouco
sobre enema de café
junto com a ozôoterapia retal?
Bem, você pode sim fazer essa
associação. Eh, o enema de café é muito
interessante para detox, para estimular
o fígado a tirar as impurezas do
organismo.
Ele estimula a circulação também
eh do sistema splânknic como um todo. O
ozônio retal vai ter uma ação também de
detox.
Eh, lembrando que o enemo de café tem
que ser feito com parcimônia. Se você
exagerar na quantidade, você pode ter
desequilíbrio eletrolítico,
desidratação,
se fizer com volume exagerado, é
possível até perforação intestinal.
Então, tomar cuidado com isso.
Então, você pode sim associar os dois
métodos, tá? Mas não é necessário
ou fundamental que faça no mesmo dia.
Vamos paraa próxima.
Doutor, qual é a sua visão sobre o uso
de canabidiol no autismo infantil? Tem
um filho de 9 anos e já tentamos alguns
medicamentos convencionais,
mas ele apresentou muitos efeitos
colaterais.
Bem, o meu filho tem autismo e ele usa,
tá? Ele usa
estrato de cannabis e temos uma boa
experiência com ele.
Hoje utilizamos CBD Full Spectrum que
ajudou bastante nas questões
inflamatórias como a rinite, porém ainda
não ainda temos dificuldade com a
atenção e a concentração.
Na sua experiência, o canabol pode
contribuir também para o foco e déficit
de atenção? Sim, existe um produto da
Health Cam, chama Focus, que é um tipo
de extrato canabal para isso, tá? Então
eu sugiro que vocês usem o Food Spectral
à noite para dormir e esse focus
de manhã. Deixa eu ver se eu acho o
focus aqui para mostrar para vocês.
Focos.
Não sei se eles têm no site. Se vocês
tiverem, eu eu mostro
aqui.
Bem, deixa eu apresentar aqui então.
Ah,
pronto.
Não sei se vocês estão vendo bem aí na
tela.
Esse aqui é o HCO.
é uma fórmula que tem THCV,
que é o tetrahidrocanaverol
com o CBG, que o canabigerol, OK? Então
ele pode ser utilizado de manhã e tem um
pouquinho de cafeína também, 50 mg. Eh,
tem que ver com a idade do seu filho,
né? Mas geralmente é seguro. Tem 50 mg
de teacrina e tem B12.
Então vai ajudar no foco clareza mental
e da suporte cognitivo,
tá? Inclusive aqui na página eles falam
em autismo aqui, ó. Mas é comendam pro
autismo.
Bem, deixa eu voltar a apresentar aqui.
Continuando a sua pergunta.
Ã, na sua experiência de pode contribuir
também para o foco déficit de atenção?
Sim, esse produto que eu mostrei na
tela, o Focus da RFC. Em quais situações
ele costuma ajudar mais
no foco e não deve ter atenção. Faz o
meticobalamina, vitamina D, K2, ácido
folínico, enzimas digestivas, carnitina,
magnésio, fosfocidina e colina, teanina,
probióticos. Então, uma boa combinação
essa que você tá usando, tá?
Tem um estudo interessante do Hospital
Universitário de Brasília, onde eu fiz a
faculdade de medicina lá em Brasília.
hospital onde fiz a primeira residência
que documentou 70% de melhora de
agressividade em autismo, irritabilidade
usando o strato de cannabis.
Agora, paraa questão de atenção mesmo,
eu recomendo esse produto que eu mostrei
para vocês na na tela, o Focus.
Você
pode também pensar em aumentar o
magnésio treonato, aumentar teanina que
ajuda no foco.
Pode pensar em na porque é comum esses
essas crianças que têm autismo terem
problema de oxidação, né? Tem estresse
oxidativo.
Tem que ver o intestino, que o intestino
em autista é um problema, geralmente tem
disbiose intestinal.
Ok?
Então, presta atenção nessas coisas.
Vamos partir pro próximo.
Até a cr mg pode ser utilizado no lugar
da cafeína?
Sim, pode ser utilizado. Eu uso, tá?
Precisa desmamar cafina? Depende da
quantidade que tá tomando e o tempo que
toma. Pode ser tomada juntos? Pode, sem
problema nenhum.
Quais são os efeitos colaterais da
teacrina?
Deixa eu ver quais são. Deixa eu ver se
eu lembro aqui. Eu não lembro de ter
visto nenhum efeito colateral de
teacrina. Não,
geralmente não da ansiedade taque
cardíaco, como é o caso da da
cafeína.
praticamente teclina não tem efeito
colateral, tá? Então é bem interessante
você ir substituindo aos poucos a cafina
pela teclina.
Qual o melhor suplemento para metástase?
É meio generalizado, né? Isso aí
eu diria que de modo geral seria a
curcumina que tem mais estudos,
mas aí você poderia associar a vitamina
D3 com2.
Você poderia est associando também
o LDN,
a trecção de baixa dosagem. Tem muita
coisa dá para associar, mas os
principais seria curcumina,
vitamina D3, K2,
trcção de baixa dosagem, você poderia
colocar uma berberina também e fazer a
dieta ketoflex.
Eh, estou utilizando dois cereais,
germen de trigo e farelo de amaranto.
O que o senhor poderia falar deles no
contexto de low carb?
Bem, germe de trigo não é low carb, tá?
Tem 51 g de carboidratos para cada 100
g.
É um carboidrato complexo,
tem baixo índice glicêmico, mas não se
encaixa bem numa dieta restritiva em
carboidratos.
E o glúten inflamatório também, né?
O farel de amaranto,
ele tem um índice eh bem mais baixo aí
de carboidratos do que o gemme de trigo.
E você pode utilizar sim se você
respeitar a quantidade que você tá
propondo de gramas de carboidrato por
dia, OK? Vai depender, porque se você tá
fazendo ultra lowcarb, que é
acetogênica, o farela de amaranto
provavelmente não vai deixar você entrar
em cetose. Agora, se fosse só uma dieta
lowcarb sem cetose, aí você poderia
estar introduzindo sim.
Como reverter sintomas de início de
demência em paciente feminina há 60 anos
com paranoia bipolaridade,
por exemplo, começou a referir que não
está em casa quando está, entre outros
sintomas.
Bem, demência é uma coisa, geralmente
demência não tem eh
alucinações, né? Se tiver alucinações,
quer dizer, na verdade tem, mas não na
Alzheimer, tá?
Existe caso de demência com alucinação,
tem que pensar em demência fronemporal
ou então doença de corpos de lii.
Eh, então tem que pesquisar bem se isso
não é um quadro psiquiátrico.
Essa demência pode est sendo
interpretados de uma maneira errada.
E tem 60 anos nessa idade é difícil ter
demência, né?
Pode ser uma doença psiquiátrica
tá sendo confundida como demência.
Aí pode ter deficiência nutricional
grave, pode ter estados inflamatórios
crônicos, disfunção mitocondrial,
hipersensibilidade ao glúten, caseína.
Primeiro tem que limpar a dieta dessa
pessoa, fazer uma dieta quetoflex, medir
todos os vitaminas, minerais e
marcadores inflamatórios,
media B12, o astrofórica D3, o cobre o
zin, homocisteína,
marcadoras de inflamação
sistêmica, né? protein sererrativa,
por exemplo, VHS,
função tirodiana, hormônios em geral, se
possível marcadores de estresse
oxidativo, né, que é 8 HDG, que é mais
difícil de fazer na
rotina, né, que é um exame de exceção,
exames de também de ácido orgânicos
urinários,
OK? Então, tem que fazer investigação
bem ampla dessa paciente aí. para saber
se é demência mesmo ou se não é um
quadro psiquiátrico confundido com
demência.
Tem casos psiquiátricos que você
consegue reverter com zinco, outros com
B3 em altas doses que é a nicotinamida.
Ah, então vai depender muito, tá, da
situação.
Como prevenir artros paciente feminina?
57 anos, com histórico familiar de
artros, gota e reumatismo.
Como assim prevenir? A pessoa já tem,
né, artros, não é isso? Ah, não, porque
tem histórico familiar. OK, tudo bem.
Então, o primeiro ponto é ver se tá no
peso adequado, né? Porque o peso
corporal aumentado vai aumentar bastante
a chance de ter artrose. Artrose é três
vezes mais comum em mulheres do que em
homens.
Praticar atividades físicas de baixo
impacto pelo menos 150 minutos semanais.
musculação três vezes por semana para
fortalecer a musculatura ao redor das
articulações,
manter uma postura adequada durante o
dia, eliminar alimentos inflamatórios
como glúten, derivados do leite
e utilizar colágeno para melhorar as
articulações.
Pode ser uma mistura de colagen tipo um.
Colágeno tipo três,
aliás, tipo três não, tipo dois. A
mistura do tipo um com tipo dois,
ô3, vitamina D, K2, antioxidantes,
chantina.
Pode ter que utilizar o PE, né, como
antiinflamatório, pommitoetanulamina,
MSM,
curcumina,
tudo isso ajuda, tá bom?
Sobre magnésio, quanto estão cinco na
mesma cápsula? Qual menor horário?
Quando estão?
Ã, você pode tomar de banhe à noite, tá?
Não tem o melhor horário, não. Qualquer
horário do dia, tá bom?
Mas obviamente que se você tiver
insônia, o melhor horário de tomar dose
mais alta é à noite,
uma hora te deitar.
Mas você pode estar tomando de manhã à
noite tranquilamente.
E se puder tomar o magnésio eh longe das
refeições, vai ter um efeito melhor, tá?
vai absorver melhor.
O Teacrine, por atuar na denenusina,
assim como a cafeína, pode prejudicar o
sono,
prejudica menos do que a cafeína?
Sim, eu já respondi isso, tá? Eh, a te
crina é bem melhor que a cafeína porque
não tem os efeitos colaterais,
porque a cafeína estimula os receptores
adrenégicos,
aumentando adrenalina,
aumentando a frequência cardíaca,
aumentando ansiedade, pode aumentar
pressão arterial, pode impactar o sono e
até a crina não ativa esses receptores
adrenégicos e ela atua principalmente
pela dopamina e pelo bloqueio de
adenosina.
Então ela é bem melhor assim para evitar
o efeito excitatório e hiperestimulante
da cafeína.
E a cafeina de liberação prolongada vai
ter efeitos colatórias, sim, tá? Não é
porque liberação prolongada que não vai
ter,
simplesmente só não vai ter pico tão
rápido.
Deixa eu ver uma coisinha só na minha
configuração aqui, porque minha voz tá
um pouco abafada pelo mecanismo aqui do
fone de tirar o som.
Deixa eu ver se eu consigo tirar isso
aqui.
Configurações.
Deixa eu ver
aqui.
Pronto, agora vai ficar melhor
para mim
usado. Não tô conseguindo mexer aqui.
Ah, tá. Acho que é aqui.
Pronto, agora melhorou.
Beleza.
Eh, esse canabis serve para os her?
Serve sim. Serve sim.
Vamos continuar aqui.
A redução ou retirada do vanitalina por
gerar fadiga mental causa maisabilidade
e ansiedade?
Sim, o sintoma de abstinência inclui
alteração de humor, fadiga mental,
agitação, irritabilidade. Isso vem
acompanhado com ansiedade.
Isso porque o corpo tava acostumado com
o estimulante, ele modula os
neurotransmissores dopamina e
noroadrenalina.
Então não deve interromper abruptamente,
porque se você fizer isso, vai ter um
efeito rebote, onde o cérebro fica num
estado de fome neurológica, entre aspas,
e vai gerar exatamente essa combinação
de fadiga com irritabilidade.
Então, o importante é você fazer o
desmame gradual como se fosse
antidepressivo, nunca fazer a retirada
abrupta.
fazendo um desbame bem conduzido, você
vai permitir o corpo se adaptar a essa
questão da dopamina da noradrenalina,
ok?
Importante, inclusive, nesse processo,
você entrar com teanina,
com glicina, com magnésio
que vão ajudar, tá? Às vezes tem que
entrar até com fenibut muito, a pessoa
for muito ansiosa.
Boa noite, doutor. Lembro-me de tu ter
feito um vídeo sobre glutamina, mas
antes de assisti-lo eu cheguei a tomar
duas a quatro vezes a mais de glutamina
e fala no vídeo que pode ser um fator
que leva o câncer. Não, não é bem isso.
É, na verdade, glutamina não provoca o
câncer, mas existe uma discussão já
longa aí se vale a pena ou não tomar
glutamina.
quem já tem o diagnóstico de câncer,
tá? Então, se você tá tomando e não tem
diagnóstico câncer, não tem
contraindicação.
Quando tomei, fiquei muito ruim, achei
que ia morrer. Estranho isso. Por que
será? Não entendi não. Isso foi uns do
anos, então eu não tomei mais. Acho que
eu posso voltar a tomar ou melhor não
utilizar pro intestino? Bem, eu não
entendi. Eu nunca vi essa reação com
glutamina, tá?
Eh, como você fala duas a quatro vezes a
mais, você quer dizer que é duas a
quatro vezes a mais do que é
recomendado?
Talvez seja isso, né? Não sei qual foi a
dose que você tomou. É possível ter
gases, inchaço, cólica com doses altas
de glutamina?
Achei que era morrer. Não sei bem qual o
sintoma, se não especificou direito.
H, então se você tomar uma dose massiva
assim de glotamente 40 g, que é uma dose
muito alta, poderia sobrecarregar o
fígado e os rins, sim, e aumentar muito
os níveis de amônio no corpo,
tá? Então pode ter sido isso que
aconteceu no seu caso aí.
Então, se você não se deu bem glutamina,
tá? Primeiro, não sei que dose tomou,
mas se foi uma dose muito excessiva,
acho que foi a quantidade, não foi a
glutamina em si, mas seria bom você
evitar de tomar glutamina,
ok?
Você
pode usar, né, o a tributirina, que é o
corebiôm, que eu falei em vídeo. Você
pode usar a fibra da acácia, né, que é o
fiber gun. Você pode usar probióticos de
boa qualidade como teste booster, tem
outras opções aí. OK.
Boa noite. O sal sem adição de iodo é
prejudicial à saúde da tireoide?
Não, não é que é prejudicial, tá? Eles
colocam iodo no sal porque antigamente
tinha bócio por falta de iodo. E a
solução de saúde pública que foi adotada
foi colocar o iodo no sal de cozinha
para as pessoas não terem bosse. Mas não
quer dizer que você tomando sal sem iodo
que vai ser prejudiciado paraa tireóide,
tá?
Se você, por exemplo, tomar o sal sem
iodo
e tomar iodo de outras fontes, por alga
marinha, você não vai ter deficiência de
iodo. Agora, de fato, se você não comer
nenhuma outra fonte de iodo e tomar o
sal sem iodo, você pode ter deficiência
de iodo e isso levar a ao bócio, né, ou
hipotiroidismo ou outra mesma
eh fadiga, ganha de peso, tipo de coisa.
Então, se você consumir algas marinhas,
frutos do mar, peixes marinhos, eh, você
provavelmente não vai precisar do sal
iodado.
Boa noite. Aquelas câvas que dão durante
a noite com muita dor nas pernas e os
dedos dos pés ficam tortos. O que que é?
Bem, pode ser uma câra noturna clássica,
é uma contração muscular involuntária
que acontece durante o repouso.
Pode causar dor aguda, pode causar
rigidez, contorção dos dedos.
É um espaço muscular que o músculo se
contrai, mas tem dificuldade em relaxar.
As casos geralmente a deficiência de
magnésio,
potássio ou cálcio,
desidratação também ou comprometimento
circulatório.
OK? Então tem que investigar essas
causas aí.
Se você toma diurético, às vezes você
pode estar perdendo potássio, por
exemplo, ou magnésio. Então isso pode
ser a causa. Se você toma estatina,
estatina pode dar dor muscular e tá
imitando uma câra.
OK? Então, o principal é tomar magnésio,
que é o que mais tem deficiência, tomar
potássio,
checar os seus níveis desses minerais no
sangue, ficar bem tratado, fazer
alongamento antes de dormir e checar sua
circulação sistêmica com cirurgião
vascular.
OK?
Boa noite, muito obrigado pela resposta
das lives. Como deve saber, sou de
Portugal e hoje gostaria de saber se a
Benéf tomar um copo de água com
bicarbonato. É bom sim. Como tenho
sempre muita azia e tenho R de AT,
pensei em perguntar se é bom tomar isso
com frequência. Pode tomar sem
problemas, tá?
Como não consigo encontrar no Airborate
beta com 200 mg, só que assim, o
bicarbonato ele não vai acidificar o seu
estômago igual a cloridate betaína. O
bicarbonato ele vai, na verdade, deixar
o seu estômago mais alcalino
temporariamente, tá? Temporariamente,
mas vai acontecer isso.
Eh, o você pode estar usando qualidade
betalha de 600 mg, assim, eh, não há
problema.
Esse 648 aí geralmente ele é bem
tolerado.
Agora a questão é o seguinte, tem que
saber a hora que você vai tomar esse
bicarbonato,
porque se você tiver muita azia
e
essa sua aia tiver associado a baixa
acidez no estômago, porque existe um
mecanismo de refluxo que é por baixa
acidez no estômago e aí você tomar, por
exemplo, bicarbonato, fica com pouca
acidez, isso pode contribuir para abrir
a a válvula do esfíncter,
desculpa, a válvula do esfíncter esofag
inferior, isso provocar o refluxo,
certo?
Boa noite. Minha esposa 48 anos,
ferretina 63, médico passou norori por
um, uma ampola por mês durante 5 meses.
De saber se a suplementação vior oral
não seria mais indicada. Para essa
ferritina aí eu não passaria injetável,
eu passaria vi oral, tá? Porque a ferina
dela não tá, ela tá discretamente baixa.
A minha meta para ela seria uns 80 de
ferritina. Então eu não daria injetável,
tá? Eu daria via oral, daria para ela
fisiogem, que é ferro com vitamina C.
Então me estranhei um pouquinho. Talvez
esse médico tá querendo vender o Nuri
por um aí, tá? Não sei se é isso, pode
ser que que seja, tomar cuidado, tá?
Então, toma o fisiogem uma dose aí, uma
cápsula meia hora antes do almoço,
a não ser que ela tenha um histórico já
comprovado de intolerância digestiva ou
baixa absorção.
Se não tiver uma contraindicação real
pro ferro, eu usaria o ferro oral, não
getável por essa dose aí, essa
quantidade fertina que ela tem.
Obrigado pela gratidão. Qual a melhor
cepa de probiótico para constipação?
peso 51 kg, toma um pouco mais de 3 L de
água. A parte dela hidrogenada, consumo
diversas fibras e pouco carboidrato.
As mais estudadas são lactobacíos
acidófilos e bífidobactérium lactis.
Então vou ajudar a aumentar o trânsito
intestinal, potencializar a absorção de
nutrientes
e você já tá fazendo hidratação,
aparentemente
já está comendo fibras, né? Então,
aparentemente você já fez seu dever de
casa.
Então, você pode mandar fazer a
princípio 1 bilhão de unidades fumadoras
de colônia por cepa, dessas duas cepas,
lactobacidos, acidófilos e bicho
bactérium lact.
E pode aumentando aos poucos até 5 ou 10
bilhões por dia, se for necessário, mas
começa com 1 bilhão de cada.
E sempre verifique como é que tá a
questão do estresse também, né, que
atrapalha o etimo intestinal.
Qual sua opinião sobre a nova pirâmide
alimentar dos Estados Unidos? É a
pirâmide que a gente tá
eh divulgando há anos, né? Eu falei isso
num vídeo que eu gravei no Instagram,
não sei se você teve a oportunidade de
ver.
Eh, deixa eu só ver uma coisinha
rapidinha, só um minutinho, pessoal.
Ah, sim. Deixa eu ver se tem mais
perguntas aqui,
tá? Não tem nenhuma pendente.
Eu penso que a dieta cogênica e low
carab seriam as melhores opções com base
nessa pirâmide. Sem dúvida, sem dúvida.
Na verdade, a mediterrânea, cetogênica,
lowcarb, dieta também, que mais?
Ah,
a paleolítica também, né? Mas ainda acho
que é possível se alimentar de grão se
houver a devida preparação. Sim, pode
fazer fermentação, como você tá falando,
né? A germinação.
Será que quanto menos glicose melhor? De
modo geral, sim. Tá? De modo geral, sim.
Eh, se você considerar que a dieta de
todo mundo tá muito inflamatória e muito
rica em carboidrato, até um certo ponto
é o que você tá falando, tá?
Agora tem um ponto da pirâmide, né, que
eles falam da dos laticínios integrais,
né?
Aí tem a questão da caseína que é
inflamatória, então tem que tomar um
certo cuidado e usar a caseí A2.
Agora, lembrando que pessoas que fazem
muita atividade física, musculação, vão
precisar de mais carboidrato, né? né?
Nesse caso, eh, você pode tá aumentando
gradualmente o carboidrato de acordo com
a atividade física, mas tem que ser
carboidrato complexo, de gestão lenta.
E o principal é sempre eliminar os
carboidratos refinados e
ultraprocessados.
É óbvio que toda dieta tem que ser
individualizada, pessoal. Isso é só uma
referência, tá? Essa nova pirâmide
alimentar.
Doutor, vou utilizar também colostro pro
intestino junto daqueles suplementos que
disse na mensagem anterior. Tinha
esquecido, me desculpe.
Ah, não sei qual a mensagem agora, mas
enfim. In colosto é muito bom pro
intestino, sim, ele tem imunoglobulinas,
lactoferrina,
fatores de crescimento que vão atuar
para reparar a barreira intestinal. Eu
vou reduzir a permeabilidade, o liquigat
vai cicatrizar o pité, né, do intestino,
né, o o
intestinal line, né, como fala em
inglês, né, a revestimento epitelial do
intestino,
promove o crescimento de bactérias
benéficas.
Então, seria uma uma boa ideia aí você
utilizar o colustrocim.
A dose é de 500 mg a 2 g por dia.
E o colustro vai harmonizar bem com
probióticos, com corebiome,
com o a fibra, né, o fibre gun. Tá bom?
Vi um vídeo do Lair Ribeiro no qual ele
falou que não concorda com reprodução
moral e se com modulação. Ah, isso é
coisa de terminologia, tá? Na verdade,
não é que ele não concorda, é porque o
conselho de medicina não gosta de ter
uma reposição hormonal, aí ele muda pra
modulação, esse tipo de coisa. É coisa
de filigrana de terminologia.
No caso de uma mulher na menopausa, você
entende que deve ser reposição hormonal
ou modulação. Isso é só filigrana,
gente, tá? A reposição hormonal não
causa dependência. Não faz sentido falar
em dependência se a pessoa não tá
produzindo mais hormônio, tá? Seria a
mesma coisa você falar assim: "Ah, estou
com dependência de, sei lá, de hormônio
tiroidiano, sendo que você tem
hipotiroidismo ou tenho dependência de
insulina. Se você é um diabetes tipo um,
não faz sentido esse conceito, tá?
Tá? Então é isso, é uma é uma questão de
terminologia, reposo hormonal com
hormônio bioidêntico, é a mesma coisa de
modulação hormonal. Tem gente que
diferencia os dois termos porque
modulação usa doses menores e reposição
doses maiores. Então é é uma coisa muito
arbitrário isso daí.
Doutor, boa tarde. O senhor pode
verificar se meu nome consta no grupo
das lives?
Parece que eu paguei algo, mas não tô
sabendo como entrar na na live.
Uai,
na verdade, o que acontece é que o
pessoal não tá lendo, tá? Eles estão
clicando lá eh seja membro e eles não
tão lendo lá a parte que explica como é
que entra no grupo e eu não posso pegar
esse link do grupo e sair distribuindo
para tudo quanto é lado, né?
Como é que eu vou conseguir eh
contactar? Você tá ao vivo, Márcio? Eu
acho que não, né? Deixa eu ver se você
tá ao vivo.
Se você tiver ao vivo, manda uma
mensagem agora, Márcio, por favor.
Eu
vou ter que dar alguma automação porque
o pessoal não presta atenção, mas eu já
chequei isso no YouTube.
Não existe uma API para isso, mas existe
uma maneira de fazer. Que bom que você
ter me lembrado. Eu vou eu vou voltar a
ver essa questão dessa automação.
Deixa eu notar o seu nome aqui.
Márcio Roberto Fernandes, tá? Para
depois eu
procurar lá.
Eu vou pro próximo.
Há um ano você fez um vídeo no YouTube
mostrando o ranking das creatinas mais
puras do Brasil. Consegue localizar o
ranking das creatinas mais puras nos
Estados Unidos?
Tá? Eh,
não tem essa informação, viu? Você tem
que buscar por selos, né, ou
certificações Creapacuri, que eu falei
no vídeo. Creacapuri, tem uma outra
chama NSF Certified for Sport
ou testes independentes de impurez dos
laboratórios, tá?
Mas eu teria que fazer uma pesquisa mais
abrangente.
E vamos ver as perguntas ao vivo.
Pronto.
Ah, comentários aqui.
A mulher pode fazer jejum de três dias,
mesmo com os hormônios desregulados por
causa da pelenopausa? Pode. No primeiro
ano da menopausa, a perda de massa
muscular e perda óssea é absurda. Os
suplementos creatina e o protein
bloqueiam a perda muscular? Não, não
bloqueiam ajudam se fizer junto com
musculação e se estiver com cálcio,
magnésio,
vitamina D, vitamina A, boro, silício,
tiver tudo em ordem, vai ajudar, não vai
impedir. Ozonôoterapia importante para
mulheres durante a menopausa, pode ser
importante sim, depende do caso. Crea
pura é o selo de pureza nos suplementos
de creatina do Brasil.
A mesma pergunta nos Estados Unidos,
qual é o selo de pureza? Acabei de
responder.
Qual seria o motivo ou diagnóstico para
um médico integrativo 200 mg de 5 ATP
para um paciente?
Para sono à noite poderia ser uma
alternativa, mas começando com 100 mg e
depois aumentando a dose se fosse
necessário, tá? Pode ser para aumentar
melatonina ou para aumentar serotonina.
Esse uso de 5 HTP.
É verdade que carne de porco é mais
saudável que carne de galinha e carne de
boi? Não, não, não tenho essa
informação. Não sei se você tirou isso,
mas não é mais nem menos, tá? Lógico,
sem considerar questões religiosas.
Exercício físico dois dias antes de
colher sangue pode alterar função
hepática,
não pode alterar algumas enzimas com a
CPK.
Aí pode aumentar CK no sangue, mas não
uma função hepática.
É só o apoio E4 que não deve consumir
muita gordura saturada. Apoie 1, 2 e 3
pode
é, tem essa recomendação pro apo só. Ata
carnívora flexível animal base low carb
possui mel. Acontece que ao consumir mel
com frequência a pessoa ficará com
esteatose devido à alta quantidade de
frutose. Lógico, se aumentar muita a
quantidade de mel, pode ter sim
esteatose pelo excesso de frutose. Sim,
pode acontecer.
Ã P.
Entra Ana Paula fez vários comentários
aí.
Boa noite, Nara Castelo.
Toda vez que eu tomo magnésio, tenho
câbras fortes nos pés e pernas. O que
fazer? Para de tomar o magnésio. Pode
ser excesso de magnésio,
pode ser que você tá tomando magnésio,
tá com deficiência cálcio, tá?
Provavelmente é isso, porque o magnésio,
o cálcio ele se competem. Então pode ser
que está com defensa de cálcio, por isso
tá com câimra. Então para de tomar
magnésio e vai fazer exame de cálcio do
sangue. Cálcio ionizado e cálcio total.
Doutor Alan, óleo essencial de coentro
do da doerra, aquela
mentais pesados.
Ah, tá. Tá falando para quel metais
pesados. Minha irmã é aromaterapeuta e
tem conhecimento para o consumo de óleos
essenciais.
Não entendi. Tem essa é uma pergunta?
Sim, pode usar o óleo essencial de
coentro. Sim, é uma marca muito boa do
terra, tá? Esse canabis serve para os é
o que eu falei. Sim, o foco serve.
Ah, pã.
Doutora Alan, reposição recente de T3. É
comum santáusas e fadiga?
Não é comum. Se você tá sentindo isso é
para parar ou reduzir a dose.
Provavelmente a dose está tomando leca é
excessiva, tá?
Que mais aqui? Doutor, qual exame eu
identifico? Disbiose, exame de fese não
traz muita inflamação. Faz o compromax.
Exame de copológico funcional do lemos
laboratório.
Se possível não posso ficar aqui. Parar
passar dements na tendin ombro. Passo o
óleo de rícino sobre o DMSO. Sim, você
pode misturar o DMSO com óleo de rícino.
Sora Paula fez uma pesquisa aqui sobre a
creatina,
tá bom? Pro Eliseu
aqui, ó. Eliseu, depois você dá uma
olhada com calma,
depois pode parar a tela, fazer a
captura da tela, né? Fazer a parada e a
captura.
Suplementos para ajudar com
esquizofrenia. Vitamina B3, nicotina
vida, zinco, cobre, complexo B, vitamina
C,
ômega-3, alfalipoico,
glutationovenosa.
Isso tudo ajuda, tá?
Isso aqui são os exames para avaliar a
câra, tá? que a pessoa tá comentando aí
que provavelmente por deficiência de de
cálcio,
tá vendo? Eh, isso aí pode acontecer.
Então é isso, pessoal. Agora são
10 pras 8. Tem mais alguma pergunta ao
vivo?
Vou esperar um pouco mais aqui, tá?
Dora Paulo, muito obrigado pelo suporte
aí, tá?
Vou colocar.
Ah, ela descobriu o chat
privado aqui. Vou colocar aqui no grupo
como ela orientou.
Bem, vamos lá.
A Alice Vog, o querido Alice Vog está ao
vivo. Obrigado aí pela sua presença.
Mando um grande abraço pro Mário. Se bem
que ele todo dia me manda mensagem, nem
precisaria, né?
Ah, boa noite. Sucesso para você também,
Tuca.
Bem, acho que eu vou encerrar, pessoal.
Tem mais perguntas? Tem.
Bem, pessoal, eh muito obrigado pela
presença de vocês. Lembrando que os
vídeos sempre ficam gravados. Eu tô
vendo que tem gente tá com dificuldade
de descobrir o link do WhatsApp. Eu acho
que eu vou ter que ver uma automação
para isso.
Grande abraço, um beijo no coração de
vocês. Ciao. Ciao.